a relationship is something that
requires constant work doc i just feel
like sometimes he's not even trying
anymore seriously he's clingy he's
terrified of being by himself given all
these strong feelings why don't you hold
hands
um he's literally reaching out for you
i'm gonna hold my hand
you gotta interlock it though if you
don't interlock it might as well just be
friends i'm
not partners
you like jump street now hey i
got a big ass raise to babysit you two
again going back to high school
no you dumb your ass look
like you about fake you going to nc
state
play i don't play why every time you
speak i'm gonna throw the up
beanbag chair hilarious shirt that
signals we drink alcohol are you two
around at school again it's the
same case do the same thing it's not
exactly the same case because uh one of
us got laid last night we're talking
missionary we're talking missionary
missionary we're talking
when i'm on top and she's on her back
damn get the back to work we need
an expert to consult i heard someone's
bringing a ton of that stuff down
to puerto mexico for spring break that's
your lead i know but we
don't know who it is
that's you that doesn't sound anything
like me it's not not you eric close your
eyes and tell me who's talking right now
schmidt being a little
look you got to take your thing to the
next level guys
spring break
[Music]
a grenade
you never know oh why are you going to
put it there it feels right
everybody know everybody
and my partner here you want to see that
product
where'd you find these gringo man the
mumford and songs concert and
diamonds
remember me i'm your best nightmare i'm
your worst nightmare
[Applause]
no what no what were you doing what am i
doing why did you try to kiss me i'm
gonna try and kiss you
no you're leaning in again you want to
kiss this is the most uncomfortable fist
fight i've ever been in
hey listen there's a grenade in my
shorts
that's my dick what about that that's my
dick also what the police